I believe as a mother and a wife you're
supposed to be selfless right you're
supposed to be the kids before me and
you're supposed to love your kids more
than anything in the world and so you
know my my mother actually had an
accidental pregnancy when she was quite
young but my mother is a selfless person
and she loved that child and she gave
him up for adoption I met him when I was
22 and I and so being and we've also
adopted kids in my family so I've been
on both sides of adoption and it's
because my parents are very selfless
people they are kind selfless people and
I think when you choose a wife and a
mother the most important trait is that
she's kind and selfless